that's not one of the top albums in the
world like the uh it's to me it's
probably one of the i i mean i i i i 400
degrees should be one of the two of the
top both classics for sure
you know why i think because his his run
wasn't as long
as
we had maybe wanted it to be juvie went
for a long
400 degrees and then i feel like
the g-code which
was okay
but i feel like 400 degrees you know a
lot of people put out an album like 400
degrees and it's like
where do you go from here because it's
such a perfect body of work
i don't think he ever this man got one
of the biggest songs in the world
trending since what what 24 years now
back that ass up is one of the greatest
it's probably the single best club song
of all time of all time of all time no
matter where you are white party white
wedding jewish wedding black wedding
ratchet club bougie club you play back
that ass up it's going up he don't get
no credit that man hard but he but he's
just melodic flow how he i agree then
he'll
bounce into that uh reggae type tone
type [ __ ] like juvia's hard one of them
ones man judy's one of them i just think
that like if you think of like
i think that he unfortunately
i think his falling out with the cash
money [ __ ] probably had a lot to do with
his run being like a little stinted
as to where wayne was
he kind of took advantage i think it's a
dog no for sure